herzlich willkommen und hallo heute am
freitag wir haben eine harte
trainingswoche hinter uns deswegen
widmen wir uns heute dem thema der
regeneration der entspannung und das
ganze machen wir mit einer black hole
mit einem tennisball oder was auch immer
ihr zuhause findet was wunders etwas
hartes mit dementsprechend rollen kennst
sowie ein nudelholz beispielsweise das
kann man sie aus der küche gerne
ausborgen und das kam als trainingsgerät
verwenden
die nici wird mitmachen ich habe das
ganze wieder leiten und heute haben wir
einen spezialgast wieder dabei und zwar
die frau korporal victoria hudson eine
speerwerferin 61 meter ist ihr
persönlicher rekord damit ist sie nur
einen halben meter unter dem
österreichischen rekord aber am besten
ist sie erklärt es kurz server und
stellt sich einmal selbst vor also hallo
ich bin die viktoria hudson ich bin 24
jahre alt und macht seit ich 17 jahre
spezialisiert den speerwurf
ich habe der bestleistung von 61 metern
und hoffe natürlich dass ich mich dieses
jahr für die olympischen spiele
qualifizieren können und hoffe auch dass
sie stattfinden werden und im zuge
dessen möchte ich natürlich auch den
österreichischen rekord brechen der
einen halben meter über meine
bestleistung liegt
okay das heißt du hast deine
bestleistung mit 61 metern
du hast mal vorher erzählt du warst bei
der letzten weltmeisterschaft in doha
mit dabei wie ist er da gegangen
ja also leider nicht so gut weil ich
verletzt war und mit schmerzen das
speerwerfen mit sich gebremst denn er
hofft natürlich dass es in zukunft
wie gehst du schon einen speer geworfen
du hast man ihn schwer geworfen ich muss
gestehen ich habe das bei einer
trainerausbildung einmal probieren
dürfen und mein persönlicher rekord ich
glaube bei zwölf oder dreizehn meter
das heißt dass einmal von den 160 sehr
weit weg aber ich glaube das ist
technisch sehr anspruchsvoll als ihr
glaube an die kraft scheitert in dem
fall nicht sondern auch viel an der
technik oder das buy-in einander kraft
alles klar
ok geklagt wir widmen uns heute dem
thema der regeneration des black hole
training hört sich jetzt wie ein
training angesagt entspannend mit ein
bisserl zwicken muskel dass sophie
kramer glaube versprechen
wichtig ist dass man uns aber dafür ab
essen aufwärmen wein durchblutet da muss
der guten sauerstoff versorgt ist der
regeneriert natürlich viel besser als
wir das jetzt gleich ohne aufwärmen
machen würde
das heißt in diesem sinn mehr wir gehen
wir mal mit standort lockeres graben am
stand und kens gern mal die arme
vorwärts kreisen und rückwärts kreisen
wie gesagt wir schauen einfach nur dass
man den kreislauf ein bisschen schwung
bringen und den muskel anregen sich
durch zu durchsichtig zu durchblutet
das ist außer krieg locker mann aus
verdrehten den oberkörper linke auf die
rechte seite und gar das becken kreisen
hände in die hüfte becken kreisen
victoria du trainierst fünf jahren als
leistungssportler wo warst du vorher bei
einem kleineren verein in bruck an der
leitha
da habe ich mit zwölf jahren begonnen
seine wechseln und davor also bevor ich
ins bundesheer gekommen weil ich in der
südstadt im leistungssport zentrum im
internat und habe da seit ich 15 bin
auch trainiert einmal kurz aus lockern
schrittstellung bei nachforschungen das
hast du bist über das sportgymnasium
quasi dann zum zur leichtathletik
gekommen
mehr oder weniger dort aus durch
professionell schon angefangen so
auszuüben und dann beim bundes jahr das
speerwerfen dann die letzten fünf jahre
auch perfektioniert so genau so wie ich
ins internat gekommen die seite wechseln
im mehrkampf training begonnen das habe
ich dann drei jahre lang gemacht und
dann habe ich zum speerwurf gewechselt
weil ich einfach märkte im zuge von
mehrkampf training das bei mir die würfe
am besten funktionieren kurz aus lockern
und mir am meisten spaß gemacht haben na
das ist ja eh perfekt laufen wir noch
mit kurzem stand wir bauen auch heute
wieder den boxer auf mit einem das heißt
weiterlaufen hände dazu ausstrecken dazu
boxen
erst von einer verletzung sprachen bei
der weltmeisterschaft passiert dass ein
speerwerfer häufig dass er verletzt ist
also ich glaube ich kenne keinen
speerwerfer auf der welt im nicht
irgendwann mal was getan hat
okay man muss halt natürlich schauen
dann mit regenerativen maßnahmen und
physiotherapie dass man das irgendwie in
den griff bekommt und das habe ich sehr
gut geschafft bis jetzt gut auslagern
das heißt daraus natürlich haben bundes
jahr die perfekten umfeldbedingungen wo
das ganze gut angelegt ist okay dann
hätte ich gesagt schauen wir uns doch
ganz kurzer mobilisieren an dass man die
gelenke anna bis und mit ins boot holen
wo ist jetzt wie gesagt keine große
belastung ist aber fordert bisschen
stützen aus dem oberkörper haben wir mit
dabei das heißt einmal das handgelenk
kreisen richtung wechseln richtung
wechseln im ellbogen kreisen das heißt
hände seitlich hoch geben
kreisende bewegungen im unterarm
richtung wechseln und wenn man einmal
schulter kreisen dazu beide schultern
einmal zurückziehen große kreise
zurückziehen und nach vor kreisen
und kurz aus lockern ausschütteln ok ich
glaube wir sagen einmal ganz gut
vorbereitet der muskeln durchblutet und
wir können mit unserem ersten mit
unserer ersten übung anfangen dafür
schnappt euch euren tennisball zu hause
war schon immer golf bald geht genauso
irgend einen kleinen ball der gewisse
härte hat zieht die schuhe aus wenn eine
sowie zoe barfuß unterwegs seid legt den
ball für euch auf dem boden steigt
einmal mit einem bein auf dem ball drauf
versucht es das gleichgewicht einmal so
zu haben das er braucht das nicht volle
gewichtsbelastung drauf sondern einfach
mal so viel wie jetzt einmal möglich ist
und versucht den ball nach vor zu rollen
zurückzuholen aber die gesamte fußsohle
abzuholen
und das spürt man schon ok auf der
linken seite auf der rechten seite
weiter voran ein bisschen weiter hinten
da zwickt da spürten aber aus und dort
spürt sich einmal hinein dort geht es
einmal mit dem ball bewusst hin kreuz
einmal darüber und versucht in diesem
punkt wo es weit mehr unangenehm ist an
dieser zeit zu verbringen und wichtig
beim black wall training an sich oder
bei dieser art des entspannungstraining
ihr dürft nicht am knochen rollen
sondern dürft immer nur am muskel das
heißt es ist ganz ganz wichtig nicht
über den knochen drüber zu rumpeln und
ihr müsst das ganze langsam machen das
heißt nicht so rasch wie möglich vor
zurück links rechts richtige anreisen
sondern langsam rollen hinein spüren und
entsprechend versuchen das ganze die
spannung loszulösen
wechselt man mal die seite nehmen wir
mal das zweite bein hier und da dasselbe
spiel zumal die ganze fußsohle ab und
versucht so einmal punkte zu finden wo
er vielleicht mehr spürt wo vielleicht
sogar ein kleiner schmerz stores und
diese punkte die auf die konzentrieren
wir uns dann in unserem workout jetzt da
in dem bis zu bleiben obwohl kleine
kreise rund um den punkt machen und dann
wieder natürlich über die ganze plan
darf fast über die ganze fußsohle drüber
rollen
ein wichtiger punkt nur für euch so
gleich am anfang an dazu es kann
beispielsweise sein jeder von euch
das zur verspannungen kopfschmerzen die
da über den nacken über den hals biss in
den kopf hinauf ziehen
das ist gerade mal für bürotätigkeit hat
ganz ganz unangenehmer schmerz und viele
glauben dann sie haben ein verspannter
halswirbelsäule und daher kommt das
problem und ich kann euch verraten
jahres kann natürlich die ursache sein
aber es kann bereits eine verspannte
planta fast eine verspannte fußsohle
weil man das falsche schuhwerk
vielleicht zu lange getragen hat
ausreichen um diese verspannungen
kopfschmerzen auszulösen
das heißt man muss in dem fall dem
körper ganzheitlich betrachten sowie
sowie gesagt hast der physiotherapeut
und die regenerativen maßnahmen seien
nicht immer nur auf die schulter in dem
fall begrenzt sondern das kann die
auslösenden auslösen ganz ganz woanders
haben ja ja so bei schulterschmerzen zum
beispiel muss man viel doch schauen dass
der kern aus leine herunter von bayern
locker ist und die gut mobilisiert ist
und das machen wir heute auch genau das
kommt dann noch mit dazu aber eines nach
dem anderen
okay von der dauer her des wollens der
sommer ganz flexibel ja das kann man
wenn man 30 sekunden rollt roitman 30
und der meinung ist es tut einem gut man
kann das aber ruhige minute oder zwei
machen wir schauen wie sie so am besten
aus geht so bei 90 sekunden ungefähr
werden uns daheim pendeln ok bevor wir
uns auf die matte begeben und
entsprechend mit der wadenmuskulatur
wirklich mit dem mit der black hole
anfangen zu arbeiten möchte ich euch
bitten noch kurz auch ihr zuhause ein
clan beweglichkeit des zu machen das
heißt ihr stellt euch hüftbreit hin
lasse mir die hände ganz locker herunter
hängen
und jetzt geht es mit dem kopf nach
unten mit dem körper nach unten und
hängt einfach mal locker da und schaut
wie weit er mit den fingerspitzen ohne
zug ohne gewalt ohne kraft die nutzer
kommt also meine zwei damen können mit
den fingerspitzen oder mit dem mit den
fingern den boden berühren ohne druck
bei mir hat es aber so weiter obenauf
also im bereich vom knöchel beim ein
oder anderen vielleicht sogar miete
vom schienbein aber wie gesagt oscar
thema richtet sich wieder auf und diese
position dem werkzeug und das wäre ganz
zum schluss dann noch einmal machen und
dann schauen ob man da an der
beweglichkeit wirklich etwas verändern
haben keinen machst dann würde
vorschlagen wir beginnen mit der
wadenmuskulatur einmal quasi platz auf
der matte nehmt eure rolle zur hand war
man da jetzt wichtig hier geht es ja und
den bereich den wir jetzt abrollen ist
vom sprunggelenk beginnt ja bis hin zum
kniegelenk beginn das heißt hier bisher
wir wollen nicht in die kniekehle hinein
und wir wollen auch nicht über die ferse
nach unten dass wir nehmen uns nur den
wadenmuskel her und den druck gestaltet
ihr wieder genau so wie man es beim ball
bereits gehabt haben das heißt so viel
druck wie ihr gerade in dem moment
aushalten so viel nebenher das kann
bedeuten hier stützt sich mit dem 2 1 ab
das kann aber auch bedeuten ihr
verschränkt die beine übereinander weil
ein bisschen mehr gewichtsbelastung
darauf braucht um entsprechend etwas zu
spüren und dort in den bereichen wo er
merkt es da sind so kleine
ungereimtheiten im muskel drinnen da
zwickt a bisserl da ist ein bisschen
unangenehm
dort kann es natürlich auch wieder drauf
gehen dort können es drauf bleiben
langsam voran zurückrollen alles möglich
so ist die vicky macht und ich vor zeigt
auf der matte ist es eine variante wie
ich auch noch etwas druck herausnehmen
kann wenn ich ein bisschen härter vom
widerstand er haben möchte dann kann ja
die rolle auf den boden legen und die
matte nur zum abstützen quasi verwenden
es genauso eine variante und hass in der
wadenmuskulatur die trainingswoche ist
schon lagen bei ist das natürlich schon
belastet und das spürt man da keine
frage
ok wechsel noch mal die seite
und auch ein ganz wichtiger punkt für
euch bitte nie nur auf einer seite
rollen wenn ihr jetzt merkt sie hat es
links agnes muskuläres problem
holzcluster klarerweise auf der linken
seite aber bitte immer auch die rechte
seite dazu wollen nie einseitig bleiben
schon immer beide seiten abdecken und
gesellschaft ja über das rollen wird man
dann teilweise auch schneller
meine damen bitte wirklich langsam und
kontrolliert rollen das heißt dass
schnelle rollen wäre eine aktivierung
für den muskel das heißt er ist dann
bereit auch leistung zu geben und das
langsame rollen ist wirklich das
entspannende rollen und wann spricht man
von schnell und langsam
das hat man so blues - wenn man einen
zentimeter pro sekunde rollt ist das
langsam und wenn man schneller rollt
dann wärs man schon schnell also
wirklich ganz bewusst ganz langsam und
die punkte die die zwischen da blaimer
kurz und dann gema erst weiter gerne
setzt da unterschiedlich die
möglichkeiten eben wie gesagt die beine
übereinander zu verschränken das bein
zeitliche abzustellen hier dosiert den
widerstand ihres jetzt den druck den er
auf der muskulatur spüren es soll aus
haltbar sein weil sobald ihr verkrampfen
anfangs die muskulatur was wehtut kennst
ja natürlich und regenerieren und kommt
auch in keiner entspannungsphase hinein
ok kurzum aus lockern auch die arme aus
schütteln weil wenn man da ist er die
ganze zeit in dieser stütz position ist
es natürlich auch unangenehm
das heißt kurz mal die arme etwas
entlasten
und dann rutscht weiter eine
muskelgruppe nach oben über das
kniegelenk hinauf und gehen auf die
oberschenkelrückseite das heißt wir
starten wieder kurz nach dem kniegelenk
nicht ja gehst von der materie der
überschuldung ist okay und erste mal vom
kniegelenk beginnend bis hin zum gesäß
aber so dass man natürlich den sitz bei
ein hacker nicht spüren das heißt wir
wollen wieder muskulär und nicht
kleckern nicht in die kniekehle hinein
und nicht wie gesagt auf den knochen
doch auch hier haben sie die variante 1
stützt sich ab dass andere rollt beide
beine übereinander wenn ein bisschen
mehr druck kommen möchte und das ist
natürlich abhängig davon was hat man
muskulär belastet im vorfeld wo spüre
ist am meisten ja wenn jetzt übungen
gemacht hat für die beinmuskulatur und
dem fall für die beiden rückseite werde
da wirklich hohe belastungen drinnen
spüren jetzt da meine die seite mehr
belastet habe oder die im vorderen
bereich der oberschenkel wer das tut hat
dort halt mehr spüren das ist jetzt ganz
individuell wie hier das eure
trainingswoche quasi gestaltet hat
wo ist die sportliche zielsetzung wir
wüssten hin natürlich zu liegt ja dieses
jahr das wäre das wäre natürlich das
ziel für heuer ja vorausgesetzt es
findet statt aber im moment schaut es
ganz gut aus
ok sechsten mal die seite und ja es gibt
in der leichtathletik große
internationale wettkämpfe wie zum
beispiel die diamond league meetingserie
das sind mehrmals pro jahr gibt es da
große wettkämpfe in shanghai in oslo
überall auf der ganzen welt und da würde
ich gern mitmachen weil gewohnt wirklich
die welt elite nur teilnehmen darf und
das wäre für mich auch ein risiko aber
man wird schon mal mit dabei ist es
natürlich das eine und das andere ist
dann wenn es trainings technische und
wettkampf technisch wirklich so passt
immer sich das glaube ich alle wünschen
dann wäre natürlich auch die zielsetzung
dann dort auch richtig erfolgreich zu
sein
genauso irgendwann einmal eine top
platzierung zu machen das ist natürlich
mein großes ziel
das ist gerade in der leichtathletik in
einer immer so einer disziplin natürlich
super super schwierig das ist schon
relativ schwierig lager diesen großen
mit den serien dürfen eigentlich nur die
besten acht bis zehn athleten pro
disziplin der welt mit werfen
und da muss man halt daneben schon
extrem hohes niveau haben dass man sich
auch wirklich durchsetzen kann
ich glaube stehst du momentan also im
moment bin ich circa top 20 der welt auf
der weltrangliste vom letzten jahr noch
mit meinen 61 metern den dance steigern
körper weise denn der natürlich trend
steigern okay dann haben wir kurz aus
locker stehen wir vielleicht einmal auf
zwischen drinnen schütteln und durch das
heißt wir haben bereits die fußsohle die
wade und die oberschenkelrückseite gibt
es eigentlich in der
oberschenkelmuskulatur an spezialbereich
der bei den speerwerfern super super
stark belastet wird bei uns sind es vor
allem die adduktoren das heißt auf der
innenseite haben wir deutliche schritte
sind das vielleicht ganz kurz mal zeigen
also der anlauf ist zuerst gerade und
daher dass dieses seitlich okay merke
die belastung kommt auf die oberschenkel
ihnen seite darauf ja genau wenn man
halt wirklich sehr aktiv aus der
innenseite auch ziehen muss die
außenseite wird bei uns auch belastet
weil wir halt uns auch so weg wegdrücken
müssen deswegen ist eigentlich der
oberschenkel rundherum sehr wichtig
aufzulockern okay dann würde ich
vorschlagen wir schauen uns gerne die
innenseite an und im anschluss die
außenseite und soviel kann ich
versprechen bei den meisten von euch
wird die innenseite weniger wird und wie
die außenseite okay aber spürt selber
spürt hinein
wir beginnen mit der innenseite das
heißt ihr geht sind eine art unterarm
stück legt wiederum ober dem kniegelenk
die rolle ab und jetzt da freut euch
quasi drüber bis in den schritt bis in
die leiste hinein und wieder zurück und
auch hier langsam rollen kontrolliert
rollen und wenn punkte da sind kann man
die natürlich entsprechend wieder eine
besondere würdigung zu führen und der
ein oder andere sekunde auch drauf
bleiben was viel belastung gehabt auf
den oberschenkeln in der woche ach ja
die woche war schon ziemlich anstrengend
gerade mitnehmen im aufbautraining ich
hoffe es geht nächste woche dann auf
trainingslager als geplant so ging es
dahin in den norden von teneriffa
da kann man ganz gut werfen und das wäre
natürlich super jetzt draußen wieder zu
werfen um zu sehen wie die wurftechnik
sich über wind entwickelt hat er derzeit
in den netzwerken und das sieht man halt
nicht wie die für genau wir werfen in
der halle in der südstadt
also muss was sagen mit frist ein
bisserl tarife um diese jahreszeit
natürlich superschön war's ja von gast
in österreich hat aber natürlich da ist
die temperatur sicherlich
ausschlaggebend dass man da ohne
handschuhe und ohne viel zusatz
bekleidung heute trainieren kann so dass
es wirklich authentisch ist
wir haben das ich habe das bevor wir in
der südstadt eine halle zum werfen
gehabt haben haben wir natürlich auch
immer draußen geworfen aber mit schal
wintermantel kam halt nicht so befreit
werfen und zieht halt den armen mal die
seite bedeuten und die technik ist hat
dann ein bisschen an formel 1 ab heute
ist und das sowieso ein sport ist der
den muskel extrem fordert und die
belastung in den gelenken da ist dann
kann sich jeder von euch zuhause
vorstellen wenn es dann kalt ist und
dann die gelenke arne permanenten unter
betriebstemperatur also
betriebstemperatur haben das natürlich
dann für verletzungen und entsprechende
probleme dass die vorprogrammiert
sondern genauso für die gelenke ist auf
jeden fall nicht sehr angenehm
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir jetzt
eine halle haben es hat seit ein paar
jahren ja die sicher viele verletzungen
verhindert hat konzentriert sich wieder
drauf auch wenn man da plaudern langsam
rollen bitte nicht zu schnell werden
weil wir gesagt haben wir wollen die
muskeln nicht aktivieren sondern wir
wollen ihn entspannen
welche disziplin wehrte einen ecke in
der leichtathletik okay das heißt in dem
fall bleibt dann in der leichtathletik
erinnert das laufen über das heißt alles
was zehn kilometer und mehr es ist 19
gut aber das war beim laufen drinnen
beim laufen bisher oberschenkel und die
vario extrem belastet das heißt die
hauptarbeiten die muskulatur das heißt
du solltest ja eigentlich sehr gut tun
super ok dann lassen wir mal die
oberschenkel innenseite und wechseln auf
die außenseite und jetzt da passt es
ganz genau auf weil damals die
opposition finden die ich aushalten kann
weil das ist wirklich wirklich
anstrengend und schmerzhaft für muskel
wenn ich da mit voller gewichtsbelastung
draufgehen
das heißt wenn ja mal bei der nici shops
die stützt sich einmal mit den armen ab
und nimmt ihren fuß zusätzlich zum
abstützen einmal für die ersten paar
bewegungen mit das heißt es ist nicht
übereinander liegend im seit stützt
sondern wir versuchen das so wenig druck
wie möglich auf die muskulatur zu
bringen weil damit ist das aushaltbar
jeweils merken wenn er das nicht macht
wird es richtig weh so dass man den
muskel gegen spanien muss und wenn ich
vor anspannen muss haben natürlich
keinen erholungseffekt mehr
ich könnte das bein vorne zum abstützen
nehmen können so hinnehmen
ihr könnt natürlich einmal probieren die
beine übereinander zu legen aber bitte
an nur dann wenn das möglich ist so dass
es einen sinn macht
er ist wie viele stunden kam es an
trainierst du wöchentlich in einer
vorbereitungsphase ja also im winter
kann es schon bis zu sechs sieben
stunden am tag kommen
an vier tagen der woche und am 56 und
habe ich einmal training statt zweimal
so insgesamt sind wahrscheinlich um die
20 stunden wenn seine intensive woche
ist mit hohen belastungen in der
kraftkammer und direkt am gerät dann
natürlich auch ihr habt genauso wie wir
haben zweimal in der woche
die restlichen einheiten weil man das
halt sonst nicht aushalten muss man
natürlich darf trainieren viel athletik
training sprint sprung machen wir viel
wenn ich jetzt nur werfen würde am
sperren würden einen shooter also mein
ganzer körper wird das glaube ich nicht
aushalten weil die belastung hat sehr
hoch es bleibt dann zeit noch für
ausgleichs sportarten magst du irgendwas
für dich für deine seele wohl quasi also
für man sehen wohl mache ich mache ich
sagen wo ich mich nicht körperlich
betätigen okay okay weil ich außerhalb
vielleicht bisschen spazieren gehen am
wochenende aber normalerweise bin ich so
fertig dass ich mich freuen wenn ich
einmal nichts machen kann also was sagt
ja wir sportler sind immer aktiv und so
aber ich bin da halt eher so dass ich
mich freuen wenn ich einmal beim rollout
nichts machen kann wechsel mal die seite
das heißt auch die regeneration mit
nichtstun ist für dich eine die ganz
wichtig weil ich hätte also zeitlich
wird sich das glaube ich auch nicht
langsam ausgehen bei mir dass ich dass
ich jetzt viele andere sportarten
ausprobieren das ist ja das was man
schon gesagt haben besser werden und
stärker werden entwickeln wird sie der
muskel ja in der pause in der
regenerationsphase das heißt im training
kann man natürlich den reiz setzen und
in der pause wird man dann stärker und
wenn die pause wenig wird weiß mit
alternativen dann auch noch gefüllt ist
dann ist natürlich dass für den haupt
sport nicht unbedingt immer so produktiv
genauso wir haben unser training ist so
aufgebaut dass wird zweieinhalb wochen
belastung haben da ist das training sehr
intensiv und dann haben wir manchmal je
nachdem wie wie anstrengend die wochen
waren drei bis vier tage frei wo ich
wirklich gar nichts nach und also auch
so spazieren gehen natürlich also auch
nicht nur um liegen aber kein training
in dem sinne und märkte halt immer wenn
ich dann am montag wieder beginnen im
training das ich total aus gut bin und
dass ich diese pause wirklich auszahlt
hat das dann ja so erinnert erkennen
total wichtig wenn ich das nicht hätte
dann wird es schlechter scheuer dann
kommt irgendwann in einer überlastung
eine und in der über training und das
ist natürlich dann denkbar ungünstig
weil da braucht man viele wochen und
monate und es auch wieder entsprechend
ausgleichen zu können
ok ich würde vorschlagen stehen wir
wieder mal zwischen drinnen outlook kann
man uns aus damit man die oberarme die
schulter entsprechend ausrasten können
weil es abstützen ist natürlich auch
eine gewisse belastung die da da ist wie
geht's dir genau das heißt wir wollen
aber kein berg hat was machen das haben
wir ja schon einmal erwähnt sondern es
so eine regenerative maßnahme sein
das heißt wenn dann die beine super
entspannt werden aber der oberkörper
100% verspannt wäre dann hätte man
natürlich jetzt da nicht das richtige
maß gefunden deswegen immer wieder pause
für die arme beim abstützen genauso ist
es okay wir sind mit den beinen fast
durch die oberschenkel vorderseite las
man jetzt einmal jetzt einmal aus nur
einmal ganz kurz nicht gesagt du uns
bitte wie das ausschauen würde
das heißt ihr geht es herrn ernst die
rolle legt euch auf die rolle drauf und
auch hier könnt ihr einfach voran
zurückrollen nachdem er jetzt aber schon
ganz viel im stützt drinnen waren und
wie gesagt eure hände annett überlassen
wollen diese variante habt ihr gesehen
wir wechseln jetzt zum gesäß
gesäßmuskulatur weil die haben wir auch
in der woche bei sämtlichen sprüngen und
kniebeugen aus verschieden wo auch immer
sehr stark belastet und die schauen wir
uns jetzt an die räume jetzt der kurz
auf dafür können sie einen ball
hernehmen an etwas größeren vans oder
einen härteren ball oder auch die rolle
beide varianten versucht auch hier
einseitigkeit zu vermeiden das heißt
setzt euch auf eine puppe hälfte auf
eine pobacke traf kreuznach forum
zurückschaut das nicht über den knochen
drüber holz sondern wirklich nur
muskulär entsprechend am gewebe da die
den druck aufbaut
also die vicky hat den ball
sitzt auf den ball traf das erkennt man
vielleicht vor der kamera nicht ganz so
gut aber die sitzt am ball traf die
micky hermacht mit der rolle
beide varianten sind gut so dass ihr
muskulär des sports und da gilt auch
dasselbe wie man bei den anderen übungen
und varianten schon gehabt haben ihr
müsst schauen dass wir entsprechend die
punkte die apotheken länger drauf bleibt
darüber rollt langsam ändern versucht
die spannung dort zu lösen dass die land
art das training trainingslager woche 14
tage sind 14 tage sind
und wie schaut dann der weitere
saisonverlauf aus sollten waren sollten
die ersten wettkämpfe seien
super wäre es wenn wenn ich fit genug
bin natürlich ende april schon
wettkämpfe zu machen auf nationaler
ebene kleine meetings und ansonsten im
mai anfang anfang mai geplantes dann
losgeht ok also hast du bist nur eine
vorbereitungszeit genau also ich als
spielerin habe keine hallensaison viele
von meinen kollegen und kolleginnen
haben die springen in der halle gibt es
hürden oder kugelstoßen und speerwerfen
das geht halt bei uns leider nicht immer
alle in finnland gibt so eine halle aber
dass das haben wir in österreich nicht
und genau deshalb geht es bei mir im mai
dann los wechselt man mal die seite
und wie gesagt dieses training diese art
des erhalts des regenerieren
das ist nach allen belastungen aus super
variante um den muskel wieder zu
entspannen um den tonus zu lösen um die
spannung herauszubringen und
entsprechend für die nächste belastung
die dann kommt auch wieder regeneriert
und leistungsfähig hinein gehen zu
können
ob das jetzt ein laufen war ob das ein
sprung training war ob das ein
krafttraining für die beine war ob das
viel stehen oder gehen und bewegung an
der frischen luft draußen war es ganz
egal da musste freut sich über diese art
der erholung jedes mal und es wird mit
jedem mal einfacher und auch besser und
weniger schmerzhafte also wenn man das
aber macht dann wird es auch so wie beim
normalen training wirklich flüssiger und
besser als die der eine oder andere
jetzt fragt wie oft wie man das in der
woche machen also als empfehlung von
meiner seite zweimal dreimal in der
woche ist es gut jeden tag würde ich es
nicht machen weil dann die belastung für
das gewebe schauen auch sehr groß wird
wird vorstand wir probieren einmal die
zweite variante im bewegungstest das
heißt wir haben schon einmal am anfang
unserer position gehabt
schauen wir mal ob sie etwas verändert
hat da ist stellt sich wieder hin gut
hilft breiter stand und lass deinen
körper wieder runter hängen und achtet
darauf wie weit kommen die fingerspitzen
jetzt sind und wenn ihr mann das
anschaut vorher wie gehe ich mit jemand
der zeigefinger die spitze
jetzt ist er da die ganzen finger quasi
unten
und ja gut die nici links neben mir kann
ja schon fast die ganze hand ablehnen
ist das ist ja der märkische wirklich
einige zentimeter an bewegung die da
drin sein und ich bin mir sicher genauso
es bei euch zu hause aus ok aufrichten
aus lockern
das heißt die unteren extremität haben
jetzt einmal gut wie abgeschlossen
und jetzt schauen wir nach dem man das
in dieser woche in zahlreichen workshops
mit drinnen hatten den rücken
das heißt entsprechend locker mal die
rückenmuskulatur die rückenstrecke noch
auf ich darf dich bitten dass das sofort
sagst wie das ausschaut
wenn ich meinen rücken auf werden wir
haben sehr viel rotation beim speerwurf
dabei und damit man ein bisschen muskeln
auch beanspruchen ist das immer ganz gut
wenn man sich so vorbeugt und eine
rotation einbaut genau wir bereiten den
muskel noch einmal vor das heißt es ist
noch einmal eine kurze erwärmung phase
und mobilität für die visuelle und
muskulatur und danach schauen wir uns an
wie kann ich das mit der black hole
richtig behandelt so dass sie auf den
mobilisierten erwärmten muskel danach
richtig entspannen kann
okay sagt dass das einmal wieder dass
mit der rolle machst was da das land ist
also mir beim werfen ist mir ganz
wichtig dass meine brustwirbelsäule
aufgelockert ist ein sehr mobil
deswegen lege ich immer die plecko
direkt eigentlich auf die
brustwirbelsäule daraufhin da ca und
bevor ich das zu rollen beginn mache ich
eigentlich immer diese bewegung und
schaue dass ich meine wirbelsäule
sozusagen um diese black hole herum grün
ok und das mache da will ich dann immer
ein bisschen auf und ab und sucht die
punkte wo es vielleicht noch ein
bisschen die wirbelsäule sich ein
bisschen japan führt und ein bisschen
unbeweglicher und macht das gleiche auf
und ab auf der wirbelsäule
das heißt ihr habt jetzt mal eine
variante im bereich der brustwirbelsäule
man hat natürlich rückenstrecke
beginnend weiter unten und händlern
weiter oben das heißt die nicht gesagt
euch jetzt noch die zweite variante
wir fangen an bei der lendenwirbelsäule
das heißt über die lendenwirbelsäule
beginnen zu holen
auch hier versuchen einmal den koffer
bis zu entspannen das heißt da ist
zumindestens in verlängerung der
gesamten wirbelsäule und wir wollen vom
anfang bis zum ende durch versucht zu
entspannen und wieder zurück und ich
kenne es ja immer wieder dass einbauen
was die viktoria zeit gesagt hat das
heißt versuchen immer wieder in
positionen auch mit der wirbelsäule
sozusagen die blackrock
so umfassen entsprechend zu umkreisen
und so räume von oben nach unten durch
da ist wichtig sagt die spannung zu
lösen den druck herauszunehmen
das ist wirklich sehr entspannend und
nur zu empfehlen
ich würde vorschlagen einmal räume noch
nachforschen langsam einmal immer noch
zurück
ok stehen wir mal auflockern wir uns
wieder durch schnittmaßnahmen den
tennisball wenn man den namen mit und
gerade für euch zu hause die viel sitzen
wir haben schon gesagt viel in einer
einwärts vorwärts rotation arbeiten am
pc beim autofahren wo auch immer ist es
wichtig wenn der muskel in dem von der
brustmuskel anfang zu verkürzen weil ich
permanent in dieser position bin ja und
es kennt fast jedes sportlers opposition
verkürzte brustmuskel und ich muss
natürlich wieder aufmachen um eine
aufrechte stolze körperhaltung
körperposition wieder hineinzukommen
und da ist der tennisball oder auch ein
golfball was ich auch immer zur
verfügung haben super variante den namen
her und rolle über den brustmuskel über
die achsel kennst 23 cm nach oben gehen
und dann spürt man da mit dem finger
hinein in die muskelfasern die spürt man
clever weil man darauf gedruckt das tut
weh und in dem bereich nimmt man dann
den ball her
prestin richtung oberkörper und rollen
langsam nach oben und nach unten das
kind sah immer wieder einbauen auch vor
dem training um den brustmuskel flexibel
zu gestalten dass sie die volle
beweglichkeit aus dem schulberg lenker
dann zur verfügung habe das ist sicher
was das brauchst du in dein training ein
oder genau das ist bei mir ganz wichtig
form werfen mache ich vor allem viel
beim brustmuskel von der auflockerung
her und auch hinten beim schulterblatt
damit die schulter wirklich ganz frei
ist da kann man auch gegen die wand zum
beispiel sich stützen mit dem ball und
draufdrücken auf der brustseite und
hinten beim schulterblatt kann man das
auch machen
okay das zeigen meistens gut sie darf
die bieten dass du dir rum drehst erst
mit dem ball kurz bitte erst jetzt da
das schulterblatt ja ist gut erkennbar
der muskel und das schulterblatt aber
über den knochen haben wir schon sagt
rohlmann nicht darüber dass es zwischen
dem schulterblatt unter wirbelsäule da
ist muskulatur drinnen und da kann
natürlich dann auch mit dem ball drüber
gehen kann oder herum
drinnen rollen also besser also die
bereiche wo ich auch dankeschön wo er
mit den beiden rollen kann
an die mauer angelehnt ja um die
entsprechend auch die volle
beweglichkeit dann in alle richtungen
vor meinem schultergelenk zu haben
ok ich glaube diesmal spart mittlerweile
oder niki wie geht's dir was gott ja
alles gut möchte ist dennoch und in
unseren zuschauern mit geben wie halten
sie die titel lockt doch was ist ein
appell
also ich würde sagen wenn einem die
decke auf den kopf fällt natürlich zu
hause weil man halt leider nicht viel
anderes machen kann einfach spazieren
gehen schauen dass man irgendwie eine
frische luft kommt und ein paar mal
vielleicht dient und solche sachen wie
blekko einbaut da fühlt man sich dann
einfach viel besser und ist halt ganz
wichtig auch jetzt dass man ein bisschen
auf seinen körper schaut die viktoria
sagt danke dass du bei uns fast täglich
gedanke durch rauchen auch okay leute
wir haben jetzt eine halbe stunde
blackrock training regeneration mit euch
gemacht macht das wiederholt sie immer
wieder
der körper wird euch danken und sie kam
mit den worten von der viktor
anschließend hinausgehen bewegen
workouts machen mit uns mittrainieren
mit uns auch regenerieren
wir sind da für euch wir kommen am
montag wieder wir freuen uns auf die
nächste einheit und schönes wochenende
bis montag